everything in the universe has so much
uncertainty this movie is very dynamic
[Music]
but it is such a beautiful symphony all
the time
[Music]
I am from Puerto Rico the town I grew up
is a tiny town in DBT Tyler like I never
knew what a ph.d degree was that some
people are acquired that I developed
diabetes when I was a child that caused
for me to develop diabetic retinopathy
and to lose my my side
[Music]
Tomita was very sad at the beginning and
I didn't want to tell anyone so the
professor will write on the blackboard
and he would write a theorem
I will hear only the chalk on the
blackboard I felt like I had been
excommunicated from the field completely
excommunicated I had never had the
opportunity to look through a telescope
but it has given me tools to rediscover
myself I am an astrophysicist into
computer scientists I study the universe
through sound the universe is big and I
want to study it on people ask how do
you do it they are used to people just
looking at this guy but sound he can
make something clear when it is not just
something clear to the human eye each
piece of data is given a sound that can
be a piano
it can be an arm or it can be a human
voice everything in the universe has its
own voice has like its own personality
the way it behaves the way it
communicates if I convert it into sound
different measurements and I listen to
them it will sound like a symphonic
orchestra you can get a sense of the
science inside of that orchestration
[Music]
in the past people spoke about the music
of the spheres
that the universe exists in this
wonderful harmony because if we only see
with our eyes our perception is very
nice
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]